bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à strasbourg pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission
reportage direction les pays bas focus
sur un mouvement un mouvement populiste
le pvv parti pour la liberté de geert
van der garde ville d'art qui a fait
scandale il ya peu en demandant si ces
électeurs voulaient plus ou moins de
marocains à grand renfort de formules
chocs et de rhétorique simpliste
les leaders de ces mouvements populistes
ont réussi à se construire une façade
respectable capte l'adhésion de citoyens
toujours plus nombreux avec en ligne de
mire les élections européennes mais
l'actualité celle ukraine l'ukraine au
bord de la guerre civile c'est vladimir
poutine qu'ils le disent l'occupation de
partisans pro russe à l'est menace le
pays
d'éclatement à kiev la capitale de
l'ukraine plutôt pro européenne c'est
assez tendue vous allez le voir regardez
notre reportage
la place maiden au centre de kiev et ses
militants pro européens toujours là ici
la place de l'europe dans ce bâtiment
vit 24 heures sur 24
ces hommes menteries ce sont des
miliciens pro kiev
la situation est tendue ils sont là pour
contrer les militants pro russe qui
voudraient s'aventurer et envahir le
bâtiment public de la capitale
notre présence est inquiète et qui fait
ce mec là
non vous inquiétez pas c'est pas en
russe c'est un journaliste français
il est là pour raconter ce qui se passe
en ukraine cela nettoie la place
les restes de la révolution qui a
destitué le président pro-russe
le 22 février dernier ici on a peur que
les violences reviennent on se rappelle
encore la soixantaine de victimes de la
place maïdan des hommes des femmes tuées
par balles par les milices pro russe du
président ianoukovitch
c'était il ya deux mois lors de la
révolution elle a décidé de voir de ses
propres yeux
elisabeth guigou est venu prendre le
pouls de la situation plutôt tendue en
ukraine
elle n'était pas seule la présidente de
la commission des affaires étrangères
était accompagnée de ses homologues
allemand et polonais c'est la première
fois que des parlementaires les pays
composant le triangle de weimar france
allemagne pologne se rendent ensemble en
mission dans un pays tiers
au menu une rencontre avec les grands
chefs de l'ex opposition en ukraine ici
avec l'ex champion de boxe vitali
klitschko
l'un des chefs de file du mouvement pro
européens en ukraine
on est européen on est européen
géographiquement dans la mentalité avec
notre culture notre histoire on est
européen et on veut construire un mode
de vie à l'européenne et ceux qui disent
que votre mouvement est un mouvement
fasciste c'est de la propagande
c'est de la propagande de moscou c'est
fou et san jose là avec l'égérie de la
révolution orange ioulia timochenko elle
a passé deux ans et demi dans les geôles
du président pro russe
ianoukovitch elle en a gardé des
séquelles elle vient d'être libérée et
candidate à la présidentielle
ukrainienne du 25 mai problème le
mouvement pro européen est divisé
klitschko et timochenko se détestent le
message de nos parlementaires est le
suivant soyez unis arrêtez d'être
divisés vous utilisé pendant la
révolution orange
vous voyez à quoi cela vous a mené un
exercice de diplomatie parlementaire ce
que nous leur avons dit c'est ce qu'il
faut qu au delà de la compétition entre
eux est normal il faut qu'il ya au moins
un message qu convergent sur la
nécessité des réformes ensuite et ça
c'est vrai que la lutte contre la
corruption est quelque chose qui doit
absolument enfin dans ce pays
être mené dans la société civile on est
plutôt pessimiste
tania est peintre ses pensées sont
plutôt sombres elle a perdu beaucoup de
ses amis lors de la révolution il ya
deux mois
ce que je demande à tous les ukrainiens
c'est de rester unie frère même dans
cette situation difficile
un ton noir du sang le tableau que tania
craint pour son pays
un crème
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par marielle de sarnez bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputé modem dei
l'alternative voulais voir ce reportage
est ce que ça sert à quelque chose
finalement c'est cette diplomatie
parlementaire ces parlementaires
français allemands polonais c'est à ne
pas oublier ça sert à témoigner ça sert
à recevoir un certain nombre de messages
et à en passer d'autres et dans une
démocratie qui est en train de se
construire de façon fragile
on le voit bien tous les jours en
ukraine je crois que c'est très
important pour eux d'avoir du soutien et
des témoignages des parties de
délégations aux sur wii je suis allé
trop je suis allé une fois au moment la
révolution orange et y retourner deux
fois une fois au mois décembre à une
fois juste en plein moment des
événements où il ya eu de nombreux morts
sur la place de maidan jeté là bas avec
guy verhostadt donc là l'actualité les
chaudes aujourd'hui en ukraine moscou
l'europe accusé moscou d'être à
l'origine des heurts dans l'est du pays
est ce que vous vous êtes marielle de
sarnez favorable à des sanctions
économiques supplémentaires contre
moscou sachant que qu'elle pénaliserait
aussi les pays qui les prendraient ces
sanctions donc la france je suis
favorable à des sanctions économiques je
suis favorable à ce que l'union
européenne reste forte unie et ferme
vis-à-vis de la russie
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
dialoguer aussi il faut trouver une
issue pour la désescalade
je veux dire tout ceci n'est pas
possible il faut que vladimir poutine
comprennent une chose c'est que les
ukrainiens sont souverains et que
l'ukraine est souveraine
il traîne n'est pas un pays dans la
gestion aux dépens de la russie donc
faut qu'il accepte cela et en même temps
moi je ne comprends pas l'intérêt de la
lumière poutine à m des chars partout à
agiter sa police militaire dans l'est a
agité les mêmes peurs transnitrie vous
savez quand vladimir poutine reçoit la
douma avait pris moi là d'où main il ya
quelques mois de ça ou quelques années
près qu'on retrouve la date exacte le
permettant aux fonds aux autorités
russes d'intervenir partout soi-disant
les intérêts des minorités russophones
seraient mises en cause dans des pays en
dehors de la russie
ce jour là il ya eu effectivement un
danger oui donc il faut que l'euro cela
ap reste ferme députée européene ces
sanctions elles pourraient se retourner
contre nous le rappelle dépend du gaz
russe très bien mais les russes il
dépend aussi de ce qu'on paye en échange
du gaz russe un 70 pour cent du gaz de
chez nous et 50 % des rentrées
financières pour eux et donc s'il ya pas
de gaz russe qui arrivent chez nous il
ya pas non plus de rentrées financières
pour lui donc c'est pas c'est pas si
simple que ça mais enfin on peut pas
rester sans rien faire il faut que
vladimir poutine comprennent que
l'ukraine veut avoir son propre avenir
son propre destin et que c'est aux
ukrainiens d'en décider et par exemple
il faut laisser faire les élections du
25 mai après moi je crois que l'ukraine
pourrait trouver un chemin avec une
constitution qui permettent une forme de
fédéralisme
si les ukrainiens en décide ainsi c'est
pas poutine de décider de la future
constitution ou de dessiner la future
ukraine sur la situation globale du nain
qui n'est pas d'accord avec vous c'est
le monsieur politique étrangère de la
rue s'il s'appelle sergueï lavrov voulez
écouter et vous réagissez juste après
la violence amaidan qui s'est terminée
avec ce des douzaines et des douzaines
de morts était considéré comme de la
démocratie tandis que les manifestations
pacifiques qui ont lieu maintenant dans
le sud est de l'ukraine sont considérés
comme terroristes et les autorités
ukrainiennes annoncent qu'ils vont
utiliser l'armé pour mener une opération
soit disant anti terroriste l'hypocrisie
dépasse les bornes alors marielle de
sarnez les terroristes des as et les
combattants de la liberté des autres ça
dépend de l'âge et accepte évidemment
parce que vienne dire la broye frau il
est dans son rôle
il était du côté du côté de poutine dans
cette affaire mais l'agression de
poutine d'abord en crimée et puis la
déstabilisation dans l'est de l'ukraine
et puis peut-être demain tant d'autres
pays proches de l'union européenne comme
la transnitrie et peut-être d'autres
corps pays tout ceci l'europe ne peut
pas et ne doit pas accepter
et donc c'est un test un aussi pour
l'autorité de l'europe
qu'est-ce que quelques risques la région
suivent ce qu'elle n'y a pas de
désescalade ça continue on peut pas
laisser avancer
vladimir poutine et conquérir les
territoires qu'ils souhaitent
réconquérir et mettre à mal la
souveraineté des pays qui entourent la
russie nous ne sommes plus à une époque
d'avant il faut devenir compétitives ne
comprennent que le monde a changé
y compris compris en europe à tout autre
sujet
marielle de sarnez vous êtes chef de
file de l'alternative modem udi en ile
de france vous allez faire campagne sur
quoi exactement
nous sommes des européens nous sommes
clairs dans la clarté nous sommes dans
la cohérence c'est une grande différence
avec on va dire les formations plutôt
traditionnelle qui nous entourent et qui
eux ont des problèmes à régler avec
l'europe qui n'ont toujours pas réglé
qui veulent faire au fond de ce scrutin
j'ai entendu le chef de l'ump dire ce
scrutin il faut que ça soit un carton
rouge pour hollande moi je dis que ce
scrutin et doit concerner d'abord le
rock est d'abord l'avenir de l'europe
mais quand ils voient tous les cinq ans
et quand même pas trop que de passer un
peu de temps pour l'avenir de l'union
peine il fait ce que vous répondez à ces
eurosceptiques ils seront tentés de
voter pour un parti populiste qui disent
que l'europe elle m'a rien apporté à moi
regarder alors à mettre des travailleurs
d'état
chez des bulgares des roumains moi je ne
trouve pas mon boulot elle m'a rien
apporté à moi qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez leur dit que ces gens là je
leur dis que nous avons une urgence et
je pense que nous devons mettre ça sur
le calendrier les cinq années qui
viennent c'est la convergence sociale et
fiscale au sein de l'union européenne
c'est à dire de faire converger tous les
systèmes sociaux et fiscaux
ça peut se décider il suffit de le
vouloir et on peut le faire en cinq ans
a fait partie des propositions qui sont
nos propositions l'europe elle doit être
las pour se recentrer sur l'essentiel
elle doit être là pour apporter un plus
de croissance pour recréer à 60 pour
favoriser la croissance
favoriser l'emploi il faut qu'on se dote
d'un instrument par exemple pour
permettre des investissements pour
recréer des grands géants européens
comme l'a été airbus en son temps il
faut qu'on mobilise les pagnes
européenne pour venir en soutien des
petites et moyennes entreprises merci
madame
on en reparlera parce que pendant ce
temps là bien évidemment je signale à
nos téléspectateurs votre livre donc
l'urgence européenne pour plus pour une
europe plus intégrée plus efficace et
plus novatrice c'est le plus important
tout alors hommes se passe avec les
peuples merci marielle de sarnez et
maintenant place aux reportages
il faut que je sois parti le pvv le
parti de la liberté de gameville d'heure
à parti populiste garde linder qui a
fait scandale récemment en lançant à ses
électeurs vous voulez moines marocain et
bien on va s'en charger et bien notre
envoyé spécial mari la bat a rencontré
garde builders regarder son reportage
donc je vous le demande voulez vous pour
cette ville et pour les pays-bas plus ou
moins de marocains
donc on va régler ça
cette vidéo a fait scandale sur les
réseaux sociaux
vu par des millions d'internautes elle
montrerait de l'île d'ars le leader du
pvv
au soir de l'élection municipale du 19
mars abominable j'ai tout de suite
trouvé ça abominable du savoir vivre
il est obligatoire d'en avoir en tant
que parti politique mais ce soir là il
n'y en avait plus du tout il tient un
meeting dans un café de la haie et ses
propos jugés racistes provoque
immédiatement un tollé chez les
néerlandais qui décide par milliers de
manifester et porter plainte
collectivement contre l'homme fait très
inhabituel aux pays bas les médias eux
aussi choisi de sortir de leur réserve
c'est très rare de la part des médias et
aussi de mon propre rédacteur en chef
qu'il dise ouvertement que c'est allé
trop loin ça tenait plus à la manière
dont ça s'est passé
cette façon de scander les propos ce qui
fait penser aux honnêtes gens
pour certains membres du parti d'extrême
droite
c'est la phrase de trop 15 cadres décide
de claquer la porte
et parmi eux le leader du pvv au
parlement européen
deux députés de la seconde chambre et
éclaireurs membres du gouvernement
provincial du très costaud on siège pour
trois ans et chaque match j'étais assis
à côté d'un membre du vvd d'origine
marocaine
zouhair al yassini c'était un mec comme
ça déborde maroc
il m'a d'ailleurs appelé pour me
féliciter mais aussi pour mme adressé
ses condoléances
j'ai été assis à côté de lui pendant
trois ans on disputait y ont rigolé
souvent et lorsqu'il a appris ce qui
s'était passé à l'est il m'a dit alors
moi aussi il faut que je parte
c'en était trop je ne pouvais plus
rester opéré vf
certes il d'un swing regrette rien
constamment entouré de ses quatre gardes
du corps
l'héritier de pim fortuyn assassiné en
2002 pour ses positions radicales envers
l'islam assume clairement ses propos je
dis cela ce que je ne regrette pas du
tout beaucoup de citoyens et de médias
néerlandais sont pour la plupart
libéraux et de gauche mais on fait la
comparaison avec les événements de la
deuxième guerre mondiale ou d'autres
choses je comprends que ça puisse faire
peur mais du coup quand ils ont compris
ce que je voulais vraiment dire quand
ils ont restitué les choses dans leur
contexte
eh bien on a repris des points dans les
sondages dans les deux dernières
semaines dans le lent des sondages même
on est plus forts qu'avant cette fameuse
soirée des élections municipales
je suis très confiant le champagne qui
ont débouché la presse et mes
adversaires politiques étaient un peu
prématurée parce que nous serons
sûrement le premier parti des pays-bas
au soir de l'élection européenne
en réalité les sondages montrent que le
pvv a bel et bien chuté dans l'opinion
onze pour cent des personnes
questionnées déclare désormais que les
chances pour qu'ils votent pour rire
devilder ont diminué en raison de ses
déclarations
en quelques jours le pvv passe ainsi de
favori un second partie du pays
au coude à coude avec le parti
travailliste est celui des conservateurs
mais pour laurent chambon politologue
aux pays bas il s'agit bien d'un calcul
stratégique qui n'est pas du tout
dogmatique il est là pour gagner des
voix
il est prêt à beaucoup de choses donc il
n'y a pas longtemps c'était beaucoup
l'islamophobie
ensuite c'est l'union européenne on a eu
les européens de l'est et à limite quel
que soit le thème qui va arriver après
600 cas quelque chose il va il va il va
sauter dessus donc à la limite si on se
retrouve avec une opinion publique
néerlandaise qui devient à nouveau pro
européenne il est capable lui même
de redevenir prend européen pour pour en
tirer des avantages
donc il faut pas sous-estimer sa
plasticité aujourd'hui la situation
s'annonce donc compliquée quand le parti
populiste dans un pays où les coalitions
sont courants je me demande un peu
quelles stratégies cherche à adopter
rêve builders
avant il était un peu en réserve mais ça
c'est parce qu'il cherchait le comprenez
maintenant il est tellement extrêmement
que cela peut attirer des électeurs et
le fait remonter dans les sondages mais
que peut-il faire de tout ça puisque
plus personne ne veut travailler avec
lui fragilisé le tapage médiatique
autour de ses propos a aussi été
révélateur d'une crise interne
les anciens membres du parti parle d'une
organisation quasi dictatorial où seul
réduit leader pouvait décider de tout de
quoi émettre quelques doutes quant à
l'issue des élections européennes aux
pays-bas élection pour laquelle le pvv
n'a pas encore trouvé sa nouvelle tête
de liste
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par bruno gollnisch bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés front national à vos
côtés mais pas forcément du même bord
politique karim zéribi bourg jour vous
êtes eurodéputés écologie les verts lors
vous venez de voir ce reportage un gain
devilder qui dit autres de marc o 4 de
marocains vous en voulez - on va s'en
charger ça vous inspire quoi ça vous
invite vous êtes da costa reportage
quand même un peu orienté vous en
conviendrez
non ça me paraît quand même assez
révélateur de ce qui se passe un petit
peu en europe si vous voulez c'est à
dire que on dissèque sur le point de
savoir si telle ou telle chose a été
guide de façon élégante convenable et
ima cissé sait combien de représentants
koala est ce que ces politiques ou non
mais les commentaires de vos collègues
des médias
est-ce que c'est politiquement correct
ce que sam les pages que c'est un
scandale est ce que c'est un dérapage
etc
on ne se préoccupe pas du tout de la
situation bon le fond le fond du
problème c'est par exemple est ce que
les pays bas qui sont un petit pays par
l'effectif de la population de 10
millions d'habitants veulent continuer à
recevoir une immigration massive qui
progressivement évidemment change la
donne de la population et qui n'est pas
contrôlée
voilà c'est un problème qui se pose dans
d'autres pays de l'union européenne où
la liberté de circulation qui était
prévu entre pays européens s'effectue
aujourd'hui à l'échelle planétaire
moi je respecte tout à fait les
marocains je respecte d'ailleurs tout à
fait le droit du maroc et il l'a montré
dans son histoire par exemple à limiter
la présence étrangère vu un certain
nombre de français qui se trouvait au
maroc en mon indépendance et qui ont été
priés ou qui ont été contraints de
repartir c'est le droit c'est le droit
du maroc mais je considère que c'est le
droit des européens aussi de limiter
aujourd'hui une immigration massive est
totalement incontrôlée il faisait rêver
le problème c'est une immigration
massive démarre au quart hollande
bien sûr que non et je ne crois pas que
votre sujet sont orientés je crois au
contraire qu'il pointe est véritablement
le malaise dans la manière dont
certaines prétendent de faire de la
politique que l'on pose la question de
l'immigration et que l'on débatte
sereinement rationnellement de ce sujet
ne me choque
aucunement et on peut parler de
l'immigration comme on peut parler de
tout autre sujet si on en parle
sérieusement
au regard de ce que l'immigration coûte
parce que l'intégration est une
politique qui coûte mais ce qu'elle
rapporte aussi en l'occurrence son autre
sujet démontrent que là on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui est totalement que janot
fob qui est totalement raciste et qui
cible une population qui parle même pas
d'immigration qui cible une population
qui la nomme les marocains et en gros
vous voulez qu'on s'acharne alors que
lorsque l'on sait qu'elle est
l'immigration aujourd'hui donc
hollandaise elle n'est pas simplement
marocaine elle vient aussi aller intra
européenne vient des pays de l'est
elle est turc elle est de donner vie à
l'origine il ya beaucoup de surinam y
est donc je la réalité c'est qu'il a
ciblé une population est derrière il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ne sont pas dites
mais connaissant bien marocain dit
musulman musulmans dit islam est donc là
effectivement il déroule y dérouler
déroule moi je suis plutôt rassuré de
voir que ce monsieur ne représente pas
les européens et que à hollande ils se
sont indignés dans la manière dont ils
voulaient du prétendez vous la poser le
débat sur emi dans ce que l'on débatte
et l'immigration
sérieusement l'europe est vieillissante
on le sait et sur le plan de la
démographie on a besoin aussi de
jeunesse on a besoin de souffle on a
besoin des larmes n'a besoin de
dynamisme et ça ne peut provenir aussi
que de l'immigration chaque grande
nation le dis chaque grand continent
l'indiquent
alors après il s'agit quel type
d'immigration quel processus
d'intégration parlons-en sérieusement et
alors là effectivement je crois qu'on
peut tenir un vrai débat sur ces
questions qui sont des sujets les
questions ce monsieur ne représente pas
les européens vont regagner sûr que non
le front national veut s'allier avec le
front le front libyen est le front
désuni
si vous voulez vous avez avec lui oui il
faut quand même quelques jours malaise
on connaissait le remercie monsieur mais
reconnaissez vous préoccuper de nous et
je me sens proche de monsieur leader sur
les questions européennes et c'est ce
qui me suffit que monsieur builder
s'exprime une circulation dense il est
con qu'il est utile m et enfin on voit
bien vous sentez la phrase une phrase
prononcée à l'ehpad à manhattan est
prononcée à l'issue d'un meeting
si la mythique d'un but dans une
municipale dans une municipale où je
suppose qu effectivement l'immigration
néerlandaises comme vous dites qu'il est
pas seulement marocaine sait très bien
qui est indonésienne qui est sereine à
bienne le fond du problème c'est que il
ya une majorité aujourd'hui enfin en
tout cas un très bon nombre de
hollandais qui disent ça suffit
voilà et je pense que c'est leur droit à
ses côtés le droit mais c'est le droit
d'interdire aux clercs qui suivent ça
veut dire nous avons essayé aussi ce que
pensent beaucoup de français
nous avons accueilli beaucoup de
personnes d'origine étrangère nous avons
des difficultés économiques il ya en ce
moment 5 millions de chômeurs par
conséquent si l'eau compris du moment
bouc-émissaire sinon c'est ce que la
tanzanie
non si je disais le voici maintenant en
ont l'intention si nous continuons à
ouvrir nos frontières sera
nécessairement à des personnes qui ne
seront pas en mesure de dassault de
subvenir à leurs besoins
cela c'est là coûte de l'argent au
contribuable français cela coûte une
fortune quoi que vous puissiez en dire
est ce à dire non
les jeunes au long de ma maison ici
quand ce sont des équipes comme ce sont
les ailiers qui travaillent se sont
quand même cela domenech d'anciper des
impôts mais n'ont pas encore le droit de
vote aux élections locales à cela 2 qui
consomment plus d'hommes qui sont quand
même en puissance ils ont fonctionné les
pronostics vous savez je le manie que ce
soit le cas joli cadeau soit
l'obligation de faire si vous faites les
questions et les réponses
on ne pourra pas dialoguer bon allez je
nie tout avait que ce soit le cas de
l'immigration actuelle l'émigration
actuelle celle qui vient par exemple
pour sortir de la querelle sur les
marocains celle qui vient de repos riant
talent c'est qu'il ya des hommes jeunes
par exemple est bien née nécessairement
ne ne peux ne peux pas trouver les
conditions d'un travail en france alors
qu'il ya cinq millions de chômeurs y ait
en france
le mal est bon dans le des marocains au
départ du lion robin comment
effectivement le débat devient le seul
élément là puisque une émulation
éléments vous avez tout à fait résonner
des airs la cible et la wind et du doigt
c'est notre droit de diaconu outre et
wigan dîner c'est aussi notre droit
c'est votre droit
derrière c'est le landais de trancher
sur le sujet des marocains monsieur
gollnisch je parle des roms
oui c'est un sujet qui est totalement je
dirais opposé voit notamment des
européens aujourd'hui mais ce mot niches
devraient le feu et fait des différences
est né non mais pas de son cv novelli va
ce que sont les visées moi je dis que
les roms ne sont pas des immigrés mais
c'est ça que je voulais cherchons des
étrangers pas croire n'importe quoi
sourire ce sont des étrangers qui montre
sur notre maison noire et donc je pense
qu'ils vont vous mettre là il y entre
les européens sinon par les amateurs de
séjours contrat jamais passé
est ce que la majorité requise de
traiter que vous avez votés ce g20
le monsieur c est le sujet général au
delà des marocains c'est est ce que les
peuples européens ont le droit de
préserver leur identité mais là il
rouvrit leur identité culturelle en
identité ethnique mais l'on m'appelle d
re sujet le ridant ne jurez que
gollnisch 1 heure que les européens
perdent leur identité perdre le relier
au soit envahi mail à l'islamisation
c'est un fan passionné des fantasmes de
la majorité présidentielle
vous faites partie elle est un peu
responsable un peu de cette montée du
populisme en europe avec ces histoires
de travailleurs détachés ces
travailleurs ou mal saoulé d'immigration
c'est un problème effectivement
d'harmonisation sociale la question des
travailleurs détachés faire si si nous
avions les mêmes règles sociales nous
n'aurions pas de problème à fait vrai
dans cette histoire de la directive
détachement des salariés c'est que nous
payons nous des charges sociales et
patronales qui sont beaucoup plus élevés
pour un salarié français que ce que l'on
ferait si on prend quelqu'un des pays de
l'est en payant des charges du pays
d'origine
doc c'est un vrai problème social mais
ne transférerons pas d'un problème
social qui est un problème sérieux
c'est un problème l'année monsieur boni
si vous avez beaucoup parlé de salaire
minimum européen de fiscalité européenne
qui sont des sujets sérieux de
mécanismes effectivement d'harmonisation
sociale ou fiscale ne dériverons pas de
ça a effectué une politique du
bouc-émissaire de l'immigré c'est un
transfert qui est facile c'est une
instrumentalisation qui fonctionne et
permettait
sont des questions sérieuses l'heure
étant de répondre sérieusement se sont à
la rue blais au social sont des
problèmes qui sont liés car c'est un
problème qui résulte du fait que la
france entre autres comme d'autres pays
européens de l'europe occidentale n'est
plus de maîtresse de ses frontières par
conséquent elle reçoit et des personnes
venues d'autres continents et des
personnes venues effectivement de pays
d'europe qui pratiquent encore le
dumping social et qui transfèrent leur
système de sécurité sociale se se
livrant ainsi à leur corps défendant
je n'accuse pas c'est malheureux
j'accuse les responsables politiques et
économiques français dont vous êtes la
seat avec je termine je termine juste ce
dumping social dont sont directement
victimes les ouvriers et de travail en
france différence entre monsieur
gollnisch et moi c'est une fait croire
il veut faire croire aux français qu'on
pourra effectivement ériger un nouveau
des frontières ce qui est totalement
même faisable et mon combat moi c'est
effectivement une europe sociale une
europe des salaires en europe qui doit
aujourd'hui convertibles et en tire au
sénat
vous êtes accès refaire je suis
totalement hostile à l'évolution
désastreuse de l'union européenne qui
empile aujourd'hui les réglementations
rien qu'aujourd'hui on a voté ou débattu
de soixante et un texte différent qu'ils
sont c'est un véritable poème à la
prévert nous enfilons les régulations
des les règlements les contraintes
bureaucratiques fiscale et de toute
nature
cependant que nous ouvrons les
frontières sans contrôle à la
concurrence de produits qui sont
fabriqués dans des conditions et
esclavage marley dans les pays du
tiers-monde financier aux flux
financiers qui met la main sur ce qui
nous reste l'appareil productif et
effectivement au flux de personnes
ce dogme de la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises et des
capitaux a des effets désastreux sais
pas si je suis content association de
boulistes je vais pas adhéré et payer
une cotisation des gens de bonne foi
pour poser la question la suivante pour
cette salariée par l'europe et cinq
députés europe
si vous êtes si cécile association de
boulistes prétend précisément décidé du
point de savoir qui vous devez recevoir
chez vous à quelle heure vous devez
sortir prélever une cotisation alors que
vous n'êtes pas intéressé par jouer
bull effectivement vous allez vous
intéressé de très près à l' association
de boulistes c'est très exactement ce
que nous faisons parce qu'il faut
bloquer cette machine qui est de mettre
vraiment une machine et ce en seconde
année elle a dit très rapide mais très
rapidement le second dit chez moi il est
anti européen il veut effectuer mettre
fin à l'europe et ça n'est pas possible
et moi je veux changer l'europe je veux
réorienter l'europe je veux une re plus
juste nom de la solidarité et de
l'harmonisation sociale
je crois que le premier sujet de la
mandature oui mis d'accord en tout cas
vous réalisez votre combat pour merci
messieurs merci d'avoir accepté notre
avis de sa foi merci ça fait deux
invitations c'est la fin de roberto à
rester avec nous sur les chaînes
parlementaires